on nous considère comme des gens très
triste d'ailleurs oui j'ai des cheveux
blancs des lunettes etc
il a de l'humour laurent courquin quand
il parle de son métier un métier bien
mal connu et souvent mal connoté celui
d'experts comptables il est également
commissaire aux comptes deux professions
distinctes la première dépend du
ministère des finances et l'autre du
ministère de la justice
un expert comptable c'est un conseil de
l'entreprise et c'est celui qui assure
la fiabilité des chiffres dans une
entreprise quelle que soit sa taille
le commissaire aux comptes c'est celui
qui assure la fiabilité des chiffres
c'est donc quelqu'un d'indépendant comme
l'expert comptable d'ailleurs mais c'est
quelqu'un d'indépendant et qui certifie
les comptes qui sont publiés par
l'entreprise
ce jour-là au chesnay il est venu avec
ses confrères à la rencontre de 600
jeunes franciliens une vraie opération
séduction
c'est un des métiers qui est à la
rencontre de tous les autres métiers
donc en fait son contraire de quelque
chose d' extrêmement diversifiée donc
c'est un des messages qu'on veut faire
passer ces métiers nécessitent sept à
huit années d'études après le bac mais
son porteur les besoins en expert
comptable et commissaire aux comptes
sont estimées à 16000 postes dans les
dix prochaines années avec des salaires
bruts de départ compris entre 28 milles
et 30000 euros par an de quoi convaincre
que ce n'est pas un métier si triste que
cela